.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Wir sitzen am Schnittplatz in Zürich,
als wir von unserem "Reporter"-
Kollegen Christof Franzen,
dem früheren Russland-Korres-
pondenten, eine E-Mail erhalten.
Ein russischer Oppositioneller habe
auf Facebook dieses Bild gepostet.
Die russische Armee soll solche
mobilen Krematorien mit sich führen,
um die eigenen Toten fortlaufend zu
verbrennen und damit zu verhindern,
dass zu Hause Särge ankommen.
Wenn das
in einem blutigen Krieg endet,
der viele Todesopfer
unter den russischen Soldaten,
aber auch unter der ukrainischen
Zivilbevölkerung fordert
und zudem die harten Sanktionen
noch Wirkung zeigen,
dann könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass die Stimmung
in der Bevölkerung kippt.
Wie wird denn der aktuelle Krieg
der eignen Bevölkerung erklärt?
Stand jetzt ist,
dass es sich nicht um einen Krieg,
sondern um eine militärische
Spezialoperation handelt
zur Unterstützung
von Donezk und Lugansk.
Freitagabend in Moskau.
Am zweiten Tag des Krieges
wird im Büro des SRF
die nächste Live-Schaltung
nach Zürich vorbereitet.
Christof Franzen vertritt derzeit
die aktuelle Russland-Korrespondentin
Luzia Tschirky, die sich zu diesem
Zeitpunkt in der Ukraine befindet.
Mehrmals täglich
ordnet er die neuesten Entwicklungen
für das Schweizer Publikum ein.
Christoph Franzen in Moskau ...
In diesem Film soll es auch um die
Hintergründe dieser Eskalation gehen.
Zusammen mit Christof Franzen
wollen wir die Handybilder,
die uns derzeit aus der Ukraine
erreichen, einordnen.
* Detonationen *
Wir wollen mit Menschen reden,
die vor diesem Krieg fliehen.
Heute Morgen um 5 Uhr
gab es in Charkiw Detonationen.
Da war für mich klar:
"Das Auto holen und los!"
Wir wollen jenen eine Stimme geben,
die dageblieben sind.
Ich blieb gestern
fast den ganzen Tag im Keller,
denn wir wissen nicht,
wann wieder Schüsse fallen werden.
Christof Franzen versucht,
wieder in Kontakt zu kommen
mit dem Ukrainer Aleksej,
der seit acht Jahren
freiwillig an der Front ist.
Und wir wollen zeigen, was das alles
mit den Maidan-Protesten
aus dem Jahr 2014 zu tun hat.
Hättest du es je
für möglich gehalten,
dass Wladimir Putin der Ukraine
den offenen Krieg erklären würde?
Diese Option bestand immer.
Von der Logik her
war es eigentlich auch zu erwarten,
dass das früher oder später
mal passiert.
Denn wenn die Ukraine
so wichtig ist ...
Wenn er wirklich verhindern wollte,
dass sie weiter
nach Westen abdriftet,
dann musste Putin aus seiner Logik
heraus etwas dagegen unternehmen.
Aber man dachte immer,
dass die Kosten zu hoch sein würden,
die so etwas verursachen würde -
insbesondere die aus den Sanktionen
resultierenden Kosten.
Dass er letztlich
tatsächlich einmarschiert,
war für viele überraschend,
auch für mich.
Was kaum jemand für möglich gehalten
hat, ist nun Realität.
Handyvideos, deren Herkunft sich
meist nicht überprüfen lässt,
geben einen Eindruck
von diesem Krieg.
* Mehrfache Detonationen *
Von eingekesselten Städten,
die unter Beschuss stehen.
Und vom Leid der Zivilbevölkerung.
* Detonation *
* Eine Frau schreckt auf,
ein Kind schreit. *
Charkiw, die zweitgrösste Stadt
der Ukraine, noch zu Friedenszeiten.
Hier haben wir Peter Wermuth
vor sechs Jahren
zum ersten Mal getroffen.
Der Berner Bauernbub
und gelernte Mechaniker
hat ein Kaffee-Imperium aufgebaut,
das in den besten Zeiten
2'500 Angestellte beschäftigte.
Dobry den.
- Dobry den.
Geht das nach Charkiw?
- Ja.
Harasho. Spasibo.
Mit dem Import von Kaffee
hat er hier ein Vermögen gemacht.
Ausserdem hat er eine landesweite
Kette mit Kaffeehäusern aufgebaut.
Heute ist er wie Hunderttausende
auf der Flucht.
Ich habe eine zwölfstündige Fahrt
hinter mir.
Nun bin ich in Krementschuk.
Wir haben noch ein Hotel gefunden.
Jemand, der auch aus Charkiw
eintraft, berichtet gerade,
alle Hotels seinen schon besetzt.
Viele Menschen sind unterwegs,
v.a. mit Kindern.
Auf den Autobahnen habe es stunden-
lange Staus gegeben, erzählt er.
Unterwegs
sei er ukrainischen Truppen begegnet,
die hätten alle Zivilisten
passieren lassen.
Als Sie die Detonationen
gehört haben,
war Ihnen sofort klar,
dass nun Krieg herrscht?
Ja, und ich war sehr überrascht,
dass es so schnell ging.
Haben Sie keine Angst?
Nein, ich habe keine Angst.
Natürlich war mir heute Morgen
bei den Detonationen mulmig zumute.
Aber Angst
habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Ich finde es seltsam, wenn jemand in
einem Kriegsgebiet keine Angst hat.
Ich war eben noch nie
ein ängstlicher Mensch.
Sonst wäre ich wohl
in den 90er-Jahren
nicht zu diesem Abenteuer in die
Ukraine und Russland aufgebrochen.
Hier lebte Wermuth
bis vor einigen Jahren
zusammen mit seiner damaligen
Partnerin und ihren vier Kindern.
Habt ihr eure Hände gewaschen?
So, und dann gibst du ...
... etwas Aromat auf die Tomaten.
Ich habe mich inzwischen
so eingelebt,
dass es sich anfühlt,
als wären es meine eigenen Kinder.
Ich bin auch froh,
dass die Kinder ein gutes Leben
und Aussichten
auf eine gute Zukunft haben.
Das gibt mir ein gutes Gefühl.
* Andauernde Detonationen *
Das älteste der Kinder,
der inzwischen 18-jährige Sascha,
schickt uns dieses Video.
Zusammen mit seinen Geschwistern
hat er sich in den Keller unter einem
von Wermuths Geschäften geflüchtet.
Denn der Krieg hat Charkiw erreicht.
Haben Sie Angst um Ihre Stiefkinder?
Ja. Ich hätte sie lieber
mitgenommen,
aber letztlich entscheidet Tatyana.
Die Kinder sollten bei ihr bleiben,
habe seine Ex-Partnerin Tatyana
gesagt.
Ich hätte die Kinder
lieber mitgenommen,
denn Charkiw
liegt in der Schusszone.
Und wenn sie
die Kriegsregeln nicht beachten
und auch Wohngebiete beschiessen ...
Das hat man ja auch
in der Donbass-Region gesehen:
Alles wurde zerstört von den rus-
sischen Kämpfern und Tschetschenen.
Der 18-jährige Sascha
macht für uns dieses Video
und wagt sich später sogar aus dem
Keller, um mit uns zu sprechen.
Du sitzt einfach da
und weisst nicht,
ob du heute rausgehen kannst
oder nicht.
Wer in Charkiw
keinen sicheren Keller gefunden hat,
der verschanzt sich derzeit
in einer U-Bahn-Station.
Wie haben Sie die Ereignisse erlebt,
als es in der Nacht
von Mittwoch auf Donnerstag losging?
Ja, das hat ...
Das war so wie ...
... wie ein Koma.
Du verstehst nicht, was passiert.
Unsere Mutter hat uns
gegen 5.30 Uhr geweckt und gesagt:
"So, wir packen nun die Koffer!"
Ich habe schnell eingepackt,
was ich konnte.
T-Shirts, Hosen -
alles, was ich schnell
in den Koffer einpacken konnte.
Oh, sie kommen jetzt.
Ah, jetzt. Hören Sie das?
Hören Sie die Raketen?
Ich muss wieder
zurück in den Keller,
weil sie wieder mit dem
Raketenbeschuss begonnen haben.
Dann friert das Bild ein.
Wir hoffen, dass wir Sascha später
wieder erreichen können.
Von Moskau aus
versucht Christof Franzen,
mit dem Ukrainer Aleksej
Kontakt aufzunehmen.
Aleksej?
Hallo, ich bin’s, Christof.
Hallo.
Wie geht's?
Es geht so, Gott sei Dank.
Alle am Leben?
Im Moment ja.
Acht Jahre vorher in Kiew:
die sog. Maidan-Proteste.
Hier hat Christof Franzen
Aleksej zum ersten Mal getroffen,
als der gerade die Leiche eines
Demonstranten hierhergetragen hatte.
Er stand neben mir
auf der Barrikade.
Dann schoss ihm ein Scharfschütze
in die Lunge.
Gerade erst vor 10 Min.
Als wir ihn wegtrugen,
sagte er noch:
"Verdammt, ich will nicht sterben."
Um die Vorgeschichte des heutigen
Krieges zu verstehen, muss man
auf die Ereignisse auf dem Maidan-
Platz Anfang 2014 zurückblicken.
Wie würdest du das einordnen?
Welche Bedeutung
hatte die sog. Maidan-Revolution?
Eigentlich hat es bereits
im Herbst 2013 begonnen.
Die Ukraine wollte damals
die Verträge mit der
Europäischen Union unterzeichnen:
einen Freihandelsvertrag
und einen Assoziierungsvertrag.
Russland machte ganz viel Druck,
aber auch finanzielle Angebote,
damit die Ukraine
diese Verträge nicht unterzeichnet.
Letztlich entschied der damalige
Präsident Wiktor Janukowytsch,
die Verträge nicht zu unterzeichnen.
Daraufhin gingen die Menschen
auf die Strasse
und die Maidan-Proteste begannen.
Auf den Strassen Kiews
verlangten Hunderttausende,
dass die Ukraine auf ihrem
europäischen Kurs bleiben sollte.
(Mann) Ukrayina tse Yevropa.
Der Präsident reagierte zunehmend
mit Polizeigewalt.
* Schwere Klänge *
Als Folge davon versammelten sich
radikale Demonstranten
auf dem Maidan.
Unter ihnen auch Bewaffnete.
Am 18. Februar 2014 begann die
Polizei mit der Räumung des Platzes.
Die Situation eskalierte.
Zwei Tage später schossen
Scharfschützen auf die Demonstranten.
Die Regierung stand am Pranger.
Das ist kein Bürgerkrieg.
Hier schiessen nicht
Brüder auf Brüder.
Hier tötet die Polizei
ihre eigenen Bürger.
Nach diesem Drama beugte sich
Präsident Janukowitsch
dem internationalen Druck
und er versprach Neuwahlen.
Dann aber flüchtete er nach Russland.
Auf Druck der Strasse?
Oder fallengelassen von seinen
Sicherheitskräften? Das blieb offen.
Das ukrainische Parlament wählte
daraufhin eine Übergangsregierung.
Der Westen dachte im ersten Moment,
er habe gewonnen,
die Ukraine würde sich nun
dem Westen annähern
und der EU,
vielleicht der NATO anschliessen.
Moskau sprach
von einer faschistischen Junta
und einem Staatsstreich.
Russland wollte, dass die Ukraine
bei ihren Institutionen mitmacht.
Als es zu den Maidan-Protesten kam,
sagte Russland,
dass diese vom Westen
finanziert worden seien
und es sich um einen
Anti-Russland-Protest handle.
Als sich dann
die Ereignisse zuspitzten
und Präsident Janukowitsch
nach Russland flüchtete
und eine pro-westliche Regierung
an die Macht kam,
empfand Wladimir Putin das
als eine grosse Niederlage.
Und was schliess er daraus?
Seine erste Reaktion war es,
die Krim zu besetzen.
Auf der ukrainischen Halbinsel Krim
tauchten Soldaten ohne Abzeichen auf.
Wer sie geschickt hatte,
wurde allerdings schnell klar.
Russe?
- Ja, klar.
Das kann man
als Vergeltungsaktion bezeichnen
oder als Aktion, bei der einfach
der Moment ausgenützt wurde.
Ich glaube, dass die Pläne für
eine Krim-Besetzung schon bestanden.
Wie hat der Westen
auf die Annexion der Krim reagiert?
Das war ein grosser Schock
für den Westen.
Der Westen hatte es nicht erwartet
und wirkte völlig überrascht.
Man hatte damit nicht gerechnet
und wusste nicht,
wie man damit umgehen sollte.
Aber man hat es
mit Sanktionen probiert.
Rückwirkend betrachtet
waren diese Sanktionen sehr schwach.
Sie haben in Russland
kein Umdenken bewirkt.
Die Ukraine kam nicht zur Ruhe.
Nun eskalierte es auch im Osten,
im Donbass, einst sowjetischer Stolz,
Hochburg der Kohlenbergwerke
und Schwerindustrie.
Bewaffnete Separatisten
besetzten Verwaltungsgebäude.
Anhänger der ukrainischen Einheit
lebten jetzt gefährlich.
Hunderte wurden entführt,
teils gefoltert oder sogar ermordet.
Viele Köpfe der Separatisten
kamen aus Russland
und russische Demonstranten
kamen Bus-weise in die Ukraine.
Gewählte ukrainische Politiker
mussten weichen.
Selbsternannte Volkstribune
traten an ihre Stelle.
Rossija! Rossija! Rossija!
Dann tauchten paramilitärische
Truppen mit schwerem Kriegsgerät auf.
Unter ihnen ehemalige Spezialeinsatz-
kräfte von Ex-Präsident Janukowitsch.
Aber auch viele Russen
und Tschetschenen.
Gewisse Menschen in der Ostukraine
waren damals unzufrieden.
Aber ich glaube, diese
Unzufriedenheit war nie so gross,
als dass sie zu einem Krieg
hätte führen müssen.
Donbass! Donbass!
Tausende verlangten in jenen Tagen im
Osten die Abspaltung von der Ukraine.
Eigentlich eine Minderheit,
wie Umfragen zeigten.
Aber sie war sehr präsent.
Bald wurde die Unabhängigkeit
der Regionen Donezk und Lugansk
verkündet.
Die Stimmen hatten die Separatisten
selbst ausgezählt. Eine Farce.
(Im Chor) Rossija!
Das massive Ja wurde weder von Kiew
noch international anerkannt.
Man hatte den Eindruck,
dass sich Russland einmischte.
Zu Beginn insbesondere
mit einer Propaganda sondergleichen.
Und da die Menschen
in der Ostukraine
v.a. russisches TV schauen,
zeigte die Propaganda volle Wirkung.
Nach der Propaganda
folgte die Unterstützung
der separatistischen Kräfte.
Die Situation
hat sich immer weiter zugespitzt -
zuerst gab es Demonstrationen,
danach folgten Schüsse
und die ersten Toten.
Danach begann eigentlich der Krieg.
Die ukrainische Übergangsregierung
schickte die Armee in den Donbass.
Diese war in einem desolaten Zustand.
Im Umgang mit ihren
pro-russischen Landsleuten
waren die kurzfristig aufgebotenen
Soldaten überfordert.
Das war die Stunde der ukrainischen
Freiwilligen-Bataillone.
Verbände nationalistischer Kämpfer,
von denen viele schon
ihren Durchhaltewillen
auf dem Maidan gezeigt hatten.
Hier traf Christof Franzen
Aleksej wieder.
Der Familienvater
und Kleinunternehmer
war aus seiner Heimatstadt
im Westen der Ukraine angereist.
Aleksej hatte zu Hause
ein kleines Lastwagenunternehmen.
Sein Zwillingsbruder
vertrat ihn dort.
Trotzdem musste er von der Front aus
ständig mithelfen.
Karasho.
Viele dieser Kämpfer hatten vor ihrem
Einsatz keine militärische Erfahrung.
Schiess schnell! Je länger du
zielst, desto schwieriger wird es.
Der nächste Kampf
kann jede Minute losgehen.
Sie können jederzeit anrufen
und sagen: "Ab in den Kampf!"
Und dann geht es los.
Wo bist du jetzt?
Ich bin
nahe der belarussischen Grenze.
Im Krieg?
Ja.
Mit wem kämpfst du?
In welchem Bataillon?
Ich bin daran,
eine Partisanen-Gruppe aufzubauen.
Partisanen?
- Ja.
Ihr habt einen mächtigen Gegner.
Wir werden hier alle beerdigen.
Bei uns ist alles klar.
Hast du all diese Jahre gekämpft?
Eigentlich ja.
Insgesamt war ich wohl
ein Jahr daheim.
Ich habe mich
um die Firma gekümmert.
Da ist alles gut.
Die Leute arbeiten.
Acht Jahre dauert der Konflikt
im Donbass inzwischen an.
2018 besuchte Christof Franzen
die Region letztmals –
zusammen mit OSZE-Beobachtern.
Eine Zeitlang
flogen hier ständig die Granaten.
Ums Haus herum habe ich
schon 38 Einschläge gezählt.
Der Hof und alles ist kaputt.
Nur mein Sohn und ich
sind noch hier.
Während den letzten acht Jahren
herrschte bereits ein Kleinkrieg.
Auf beiden Seiten
gab es Schützengräben.
Das sind ziemlich fixe Positionen.
Je nach politischer Konjunktur
hat man mehr oder weniger
aufeinander geschossen.
Aber Terraingewinne
gab es praktisch keine mehr.
Bei diesem Krieg
wurde also nicht um Land gekämpft,
sondern um politische Forderungen.
2015 hatte noch alles nach einer
friedlichen Lösung ausgesehen:
dank dem Minsker
Waffenstillstandsabkommen.
Man hatte das Gefühl,
dass man mit diesen Verträgen,
für welche die Ukrainer
den Separatisten in der Ostukraine
grosse Zugeständnisse machen
mussten, habe Russland gewonnen.
Doch diese Verträge
wurden danach nicht umgesetzt -
weder von der russischen
noch von der ukrainischen Seite.
Russland hat zugewartet und immer
wieder mal die Kämpfe eskaliert -
in der Hoffnung, die Ukrainer
weichzuklopfen. Aber erfolglos.
Die Ukrainer
wurden immer prowestlicher
und haben sich immer mehr in die
europäische Wirtschaft integriert,
haben weniger mit Russland
Geschäfte gemacht.
Es ist möglich, dass Wladimir Putin
jetzt einfach gesagt hat:
"Wenn ich die Ukraine nicht jetzt
zurückhole, ist es danach zu spät."
Am 24. Februar 2022
befahl der russische Präsident
den Einmarsch in die Ukraine.
Seither gibt es Luftangriffe.
* Knall *
Durch Charkiw, die zweitgrösste Stadt
der Ukraine, rollen Panzer.
Trotzdem gelingt es uns, den 18-
jährigen Sascha wieder zu erreichen.
Es gab vorher wieder eine
Artillerie-Attacke auf Zivilgebäude.
Es war wieder eine Luftattacke.
Es wurde Raketen
von den Grenzen Charkows
ins Zentrum geschossen.
Wenn wir Licht haben, zeigt das
zumindest, dass wir WLAN haben.
Lasst sie kommen!
Mariupol, der ganze Donbass
und unser heiliges ukrainisches Land
wird euer Grab.
Willkommen in der Hölle.
Ruhm der Ukraine!
Dank WLAN
bekommt Sascha solche Videos,
die derzeit unter
jungen Ukrainern kursieren.
Die Botschaft:
Wer kann, soll zu den Waffen greifen
und sein Land verteidigen.
* Derbe Bässe *
Ich kann jetzt nicht wegfahren.
Das Gericht hat bereits
ein Gesetz verabschiedet,
dass alle Personen ab 18 bis 60
Jahren mobilisiert sein müssen,
um das Land
gegen Russland zu verteidigen.
Ich verstehe,
dass ich sterben kann.
Aber ich weiss, dass ich für meine
Familie, für meine Freunde -
für alle, die mich kennen ...
Alle, die in der Ukraine
gestorben sind, werden Helden sein.
Sie sind gestorben für die Idee
der ukrainischen Nation.
* Schusssalven *
Internationale Beobachter
sind beeindruckt
vom Widerstandsgeist der Ukrainer.
Putins Armee
scheint langsamer voranzukommen,
als sich das der Kreml vorgestellt
hat. Dazu kommen Nachschubprobleme.
Weil sie kein Benzin mehr haben,
müssen diese Russen zu Fuss weiter.
(Frau) Ruhm der Ukraine!
Habt ihr Minen vergraben?
(Mann) Geht nach Hause!
Unsere Kinder rennen hier rum.
Geht lebendig wieder nach Hause.
Dieser Krieg
kann sich noch lange hinziehen.
Wie viel Leid der Zivilbevölkerung
noch bevorsteht, ist nicht absehbar.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Du kennst Russland sehr gut und hast
viele Jahre über Russland berichtet.
Erschüttern die aktuellen Ereignisse
deinen Blick auf Russland?
Ich bin sehr enttäuscht
und auch traurig.
Ich habe zwölf Jahre
in diesem Land gelebt.
Meine Frau und meine Kinder
sind Doppelbürger.
Ich hätte mir natürlich
ein ganz anderes Russland gewünscht.
Und ich glaube, Russland
könnte auch ein anderes Land sein.
Es könnte nach wie vor
ein stolzes Land sein,
aber auf einem anderen Weg
rechtsstaatlicher, erfolgreicher.
In diesem Land
gibt es so viel Potenzial.
Es gibt so viele couragierte,
gescheite junge Menschen,
die etwas machen wollen,
die vif sind und Risiken eingehen,
die sich am Leben erfreuen ...
Ich habe das Gefühl:
Die brauchen den Krieg nicht.
Das Ganze jetzt
ist völlig hirnrissig.
Mit diesen Ereignissen
wird Hass geschürt -
auf Jahre hinaus,
vielleicht sogar auf Jahrzehnte.
Das finde ich sehr enttäuschend.
Und die Ukraine?
Was dieser Krieg für die Ukraine
und ihn selbst bedeutet,
das will Christof Franzen
von Aleksej wissen,
der gerade an der Front steht.
Meine Kinder wissen nicht,
wie man ohne Krieg lebt.
Aber meine Grosskinder
haben eine grosse Chance zu leben,
ohne zu wissen, was Krieg ist.
Du kannst jetzt feige sein
und später in Sklaverei sterben.
Ich will nicht,
dass meine Kinder so leben,
wie man in Russland oder
in Belarus oder in Nordkorea lebt.
Ihr Leben muss einen Sinn haben.
Darum ist es das Schicksal
der Ukraine, diesen Weg zu gehen.
Durch unser Blut finden wir
wahre Freiheit.
Zum Schluss etwas Positives:
Peter Wermuth hat es geschafft.
Er ist zurück in der Schweiz.
Guten Tag.
- Grüezi, Herr Wermuth.
Willkommen zu Hause.
- Danke.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Mir persönlich geht es immer gut.
Sind Sie froh,
wieder in der Schweiz zu sein?
Ja, natürlich.
Es ist ein anderes
Sicherheitsgefühl,
als ich in Charkiw erlebt habe,
auf dieser Odyssee in die Schweiz.
Diese Ereignisse mitzuerleben,
war schon krass.
Bombeneinschläge und alles.
Ich habe das zum ersten Mal erlebt.
All jene Menschen,
die jetzt noch dort sind
und all das miterleben müssen ...
Kein Wunder, werden
all diese Menschen traumatisiert.
Vier Tage war er unterwegs.
Er sei gerade noch
rechtzeitig losgefahren,
bevor die Russen ihm den Fluchtweg
abschneiden konnten.
Ist Ihr wirtschaftliches Lebenswerk
mit diesem Krieg nun ruiniert?
Wahrscheinlich nicht das ganze.
Die Kaffeehäuser
sind im ganzen Land verteilt.
Und was es sonst noch ...
Aber natürlich
wird vieles kaputtgehen.
Vieles wird auch zufällig sein -
je nach dem, was sie treffen.
Scheinbar werden nun auch
Wohngebiete bombardiert.
Das ist ein Kriegsverbrechen.
Dadurch kann viel kaputtgehen.
Darum mache er sich grosse Sorgen
um die Kinder.
Die Menschen
verharren in den Kellern.
So wie es aussieht,
leistet die ukrainische Armee viel
mehr Gegenwehr als er es sich wohl
in seinen schlechtesten Träumen
hätte ausmalen können.
Haben Sie Angst um die Kinder?
Ja, das ist klar.
Ich habe aber auch Vertrauen,
dass ihnen in diesem Keller da
nichts passiert.
Aber ich habe gerade auch
von einer Geschäftspartnerin
in der Ukraine gehört,
dass ihr Bruder Richtung Donbass ...
Er bietet Reifen, Service usw. an.
Dort sind Panzer vorbeigerollt.
Hunderte von Panzern.
Nun gibt es dort auch kaputte
Panzer, die sie reparieren.
Die Russen stürmten Privathäuser
und plünderten alles.
Esswaren und alles.
Und die sind nun dort
und haben nichts zu essen.
Es ist unglaublich,
was sich die erlauben und machen.
Vielen Dank, dass Sie da waren.
- Nichts zu danken.
Es hat mich auch gefreut, dass ich
meine Erfahrungen teilen konnte.
Danke.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services